I want to
um ask you because I mean one of the
things that I came to realize after
going through your book is that I need
an assistant
um I'm I'm a company of one yes you do I
was like yeah I gotta do this company
one thing I read the book you know a few
years ago I was like oh yeah this is
totally me I don't want employees I
don't want contractors I don't want any
of these obligations any of these
headaches any of these meatballs you
know cause me nightmares so I went to
company one route now I figured out what
my
um what did you call it the uh estimated
hourly rate by your buyback rate yeah so
my buyback rate's about four grand right
yeah so I clearly need to get myself you
know an assistant so can you talk about
the notion of a company of one I'm sure
you're familiar with the concept totally
yeah how does that um
well here's the thing and I I guess I'll
tell you a story my buddy Mike who you
you may know he's from Toronto he he
he's let he's given me permission to
tell the story because he sent me these
two messages on Facebook and um he read
my book when it came out because he's
you know he's one of those guys kind of
like us rich we don't see each other
often but we're friends on social media
so like he'd watch me and he'd he'd had
put me in this like Camp of Hustler and
aggressive and get done and just go
go go and all this stuff and he sends me
this message after he reads my book and
he pretty much states that he goes I
read your book and first off I want to
apologize because I thought you were
this way and now that I've read your
book I realize you believe in the same
things I believe in work life
integration Family Health balance like
it's aggressive balance because like at
the same time I would wake up at four in
the morning and I get done like I'm
not I'm not one that's gonna sit on a
beach and do nothing right and and and
he so he that was like message number
one 92nd or the 60 second cap on
Facebook and then it was fun because on
the second one he goes
and the other thing I want you to know
is my last company left me and I'm
paraphrasing okay but left me
essentially emotionally scarred where I
said I'd never want to do another
company like that so his new company has
created this great life that he has and
he's happy with it it's the company of
one style because it provides all the
things he wants Etc but then he says and
this was the comma butt if I truly say I
want to serve as many people as I say I
do then I've realized I'm full of crap
because I could do way more if I
implemented some of the stuff in your
book
and I'm gonna go do that and I go that's
why I wrote the book that's why the
subtitle of the book is create your
Empire because first and foremost I want
to teach every entrepreneur how to
create a life of unlimited creation that
they never have to retire from and
that's an individualized area for every
person whatever their output creatively
is I just want them to never feel
constrained based on their time what
they can put out that's why specifically
in the book I use Andy Warhol I use
Oprah I use but I use a ton of people to
say like these very creative people
Steve Jobs Etc that you guys all know
they implemented this stuff to actually
live a high caliber life and create
massive amount of output that served a
lot of people and very unique and
creative ways right that most people I
until you learn this stuff you're like
oh I didn't know that I didn't know the
the author wrote a bunch of books and
he's been dead for 20 years because
there's a whole structure on how books
are written like I mean it's just
fascinating once you understand how some
of these creative projects work work and
um so that would be my thing to you is
like I just want you to live a a higher
caliber of work Rich where if you are
doing something it is something that is
green lights you up and I talk about
this in the book and B makes that
buyback rate go from four to five to six
to ten thousand right and if those two
things are true I just can't see a world
where you wouldn't want to do that and
if that requires you to you know and it
could be a change of the vehicle that
you're in the business vehicle so that
you can get higher leverage it could be
uh definitely the assistant I mean it's
just the lowest hanging fruit where
you're like hey there's all these things
I just don't want to do anymore that
have to be done and when I get that time
back I'm going to go work on these
projects that are going to give me more
leverage I mean that's that's the big
thing so it's there's four Master skills
okay Naval ravacon talked about this a
long time ago he's one of my mentors
from the valley and you know Alex romozy
renamed them to the four C's right and I
really like it and they've all talk call
them something else but the four C's of
the master skills is what I call it is
first one is uh Capital we all know
Capital so it's like to the degree that
you can Master Capital you have one of
the master skills of Leverage
the second master skill is content now
content shows up in a different format
playbooks is a form so can you create
great playbooks that other people can
follow to get the same results do you
create content like this podcast the
fractional cost of 10 million people
watching this versus 10 is zero I'm
pretty sure right like there's no maybe
like it's on YouTube it's hosted
whatever no cost huge leverage content
third is uh code software Automation and
today AI like fascinating like you know
AI isn't going to take your job somebody
that's using AI is going to take your
job right off the bat period full stop
and then the fourth C is collaboration
it's the people side it's labor and
that's what I I speak heavily about in
my book is how do you create the
structure where as you grow you don't
hire people to grow your business you
hire people to buy back your time so
that if you do it that way it's
impossible for you to actually build a
life that you hate it's impossible
because you can't bring somebody on your
your team unless they buy time out of
your calendar which makes your life
better to go do the thing that only you
can do and you do it in a way following
the buyback rate principle so that you
don't also build what I see a lot of
people do which is build a top heavy
company and then grow and make less
profit
um I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out